Welcome to the first episode of the Hidden Brain Podcast, I'm Shankar Vedanta. You may know me as NPR social science correspondent or the author of the Hidden Brain, a book about unconscious bias. I love making connections between the things I see every day and the world of psychology, sociology and economics. This podcast is going to be a conversation about the unseen patterns in our lives. Today I'm going to tell you about a communication problem in many relationships. It's not obvious, but it's so common that as you hear about it,
欢迎收听“隐藏的大脑”播客第一期，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。也许你认识我，我是NPR的社会科学记者，也是探讨无意识偏见的《隐藏的大脑》一书的作者。我喜欢把我每天看到的事物与心理学、社会学和经济学世界联系起来。本期播客将探讨我们生活中的隐形模式。今天我将和大家聊聊许多亲密关系中都存在的一个沟通问题。这个问题虽然不太起眼，但却极为普遍，当你听完之后，
you're going to think of half a dozen examples where this has happened in your own life. I'm also going to play a rapid fire game with a friend to tell you four ways you can become a better communicator. Then, I'm going to talk with comedian Michel about the importance of incorporating rituals into our busy lives. We're going to talk about human behavior in lots of different ways on this podcast. We're going to have stories, conversations, and we're also going to play lots and lots of games.
你脑海中一定会浮现出好几个在你亲身经历中发生过的类似例子。我还将和一位朋友进行一轮快问快答，告诉你成为更好沟通者的四种方法。接着，我将与喜剧演员米歇尔（Michel）探讨将仪式感融入我们忙碌生活的重要性。在本期播客中，我们将从许多不同的角度探讨人类行为。我们会讲述故事、进行对话，还会玩很多很多的游戏。
Today, we're going to play a music game. I've asked a colleague on NPR Science Test to join me. He's Adam Cole. Hi, Adam. Hi, Shankar. Great to be here. Adam runs a science YouTube channel called Sckunk Bear. He's a musician, artist, or around Renaissance guy.
今天我们要玩一个音乐游戏。我邀请了NPR科学栏目的一位同事加入我们，他就是亚当·科尔（Adam Cole）。你好，亚当。你好，香卡。很高兴能来到这里。亚当运营着一个名为“臭鼬熊”（Skunk Bear）的科学YouTube频道。他是一位音乐家、艺术家，可以说是一个全能的多面手。
What an intro. Adam, for today's music game, I'm going to give you a challenge. Alright, I want you to listen to all the segments in today's episode and come up with a song that stitches all of the science together. Are you ready, Adam? I'm on Capping My Pin. Alright, let's get started. First up, author Sheila Hien.
真是个精彩的开场。亚当，对于今天的音乐游戏，我要给你一个挑战。好吧，我希望你听完今天节目中的所有环节，然后创作一首歌，把这些科学内容串联起来。准备好了吗，亚当？我已经把笔帽拔掉了。好的，我们开始吧。首先出场的是作家希拉·海因（Sheila Hien）。
Along with Douglas Stone, Sheila recently wrote a book called Thanks for the Feedback, the Science and Art of Receiving Feedback Well. One concept in the book focuses on something called Switch Tracking. So Switch Tracking is a pattern in feedback conversations that is so common that it's instantly recognizable, which is that someone gives you feedback and your reactions to that feedback changes the subject. That's Sheila. So a switch track is that place where the track is going along and then there is a switch and depending on which way the switch is turned the train will glide smoothly onto a second track or stay on the first track. She uses a scene from the 2006 TV series Lucky Louis to illustrate how Switch Tracking works.
希拉最近与道格拉斯·斯通（Douglas Stone）合著了一本书，书名叫《感谢反馈：接收反馈的科学与艺术》（Thanks for the Feedback, the Science and Art of Receiving Feedback Well）。书中的一个概念侧重于一种叫做“转换轨道”（Switch Tracking）的现象。“转换轨道”是反馈对话中一种非常普遍且极易被识别的模式，即当别人给你反馈时，你对该反馈的反应却转移了话题。这就是希拉的观点。所以，转换轨道就像是火车在轨道上行驶，前方出现了一个岔道，根据岔道转向的不同，火车会平稳地滑上第二条轨道，或者继续留在第一条轨道上。她用2006年电视剧《路易不容易》（Lucky Louis）中的一个场景来阐述“转换轨道”是如何运作的。
Louis and his wife Kim are getting ready for a child-free romantic weekend, and Louis has just bought Kim some red roses. So what's happening is a conversation starts, Listen, try not to take this the wrong way, okay? But if we're going to be married for the next 30 years, I need you to know that red roses are not my thing. The first person stays on their own track, the second person actually smoothly switches to a different topic,
路易和他的妻子金（Kim）正准备度过一个没有孩子打扰的浪漫周末，路易刚刚给金买了一些红玫瑰。事情是这样的，对话开始了：“听着，尽量别想歪，好吗？但如果我们还要做30年夫妻的话，我需要让你知道，红玫瑰不是我的菜。”第一个人坚持自己的话题，而第二个人实际上顺畅地切换到了另一个话题，
which is their own reaction to the feedback and often the feedback that they have themselves for the first person. Okay, well, can I critique how you just told me that? And they just get further and further apart, right? And they don't even realize that they're going in different directions. I've told you before that I don't like red roses. Remember? I just think that you should have thanked me for the flowers first, and then said the thing about the roses.
也就是他们自己对反馈的反应，并且通常是他们对第一个人给出的反馈。好吧，那我能评价一下你刚才对我说这话的方式吗？然后他们越走越远，对吧？甚至都没有意识到他们正在走向不同的方向。“我以前就跟你说过，我不喜欢红玫瑰。记得吗？”“我只是觉得你应该先为花谢谢我，然后再说玫瑰的事。”
There are really two topics on the table, right? Kim's topic is you don't listen to me, and Louis's topic is you don't appreciate me. Still, it's a gift. So I guess I don't think it matters what it is. You should still thank me, right? Yeah, but you see, I don't necessarily think I should thank you for giving me something that I've specifically told you that I don't like.
桌面上其实有两个话题，对吧？金的话题是“你根本不听我说话”，而路易的话题是“你一点也不感激我”。“不管怎样，这是件礼物。所以我觉得它是什么并不重要。你还是应该谢谢我，对吧？”“对，但是你看，我并不觉得我非得感谢你送我一件我明确说过不喜欢的东西。”
That's all. And each of them is hearing the whole conversation through the lens of their own topic. So in this case, they're not even really realizing that there are two topics on the table, I think. What I find fascinating, Sheila, is that the person who is receiving the feedback initially doesn't realize that they're switching tracks, that they don't actually, it's not a conscious decision to say, I recognize this person is giving me feedback. I'm uncomfortable with this topic.
仅此而已。他们每个人都是通过自己话题的视角来听完整场对话的。所以在这种情况下，我认为他们甚至没有真正意识到桌面上其实有两个话题。希拉，我觉得最迷人的是，最初接收反馈的那个人并没有意识到自己在转换轨道，他们实际上并不是出于有意识的决定去说：“我认出这个人正在给我反馈。我对这个话题感到不舒服。
I am strategically going to change the conversation to something else. It's not happening at that level, is it? It's not happening at that level at all. And what's interesting is, so for the person doing the switch tracking, you're just thinking, well, that's actually not the most important thing that we need to talk about. What we need to talk about is your problem. The person who started the conversation sometimes actually does realize that the other person's
我要战略性地把对话转向其他事情。”事情并不是在这个层面发生的，对吧？完全不是在这个层面发生的。有趣的是，对于进行转换轨道的那个人来说，你只是在想：“嗯，这其实不是我们需要谈论的最重要的事情。我们需要谈论的是你的问题。”而发起对话的那个人有时确实会意识到对方在
changing the topic, and they view it as making excuses or distracting or trying to take us off on a tangent. And to the second person, it's not a tangent at all. It's the most important thing going on. So that's what the fight then becomes about. So we're both aware we're having an argument. And the real argument is about what's the most important topic here between us. What happens when both people feel that topic is so much more important than the other
转换话题，他们会认为这是在找借口、转移注意力或者试图把话题扯到不相干的地方。但对于第二个人来说，这绝不是扯远了。这是最重要的事情。于是，争论的焦点就变成了这个。所以我们双方都知道我们在争吵。而真正的争论在于，我们之间最重要的话题到底是什么。当双方都觉得对方的话题远不如自己的话题重要，
person's topic that neither is willing to give away. Um, your sunk. But, but that, that dilemma in and of itself then is the topic of the conversation, which is, I'm so frustrated or upset or whatever that I can't actually engage with your topic. Yeah, I think this happens so often in conversations and one of the things you point out in your chapter, which I found really intriguing, is sometimes the switch tracking happens inside one person's head, and not actually saying it aloud. Can you talk about that for a second? Yeah, and I think that that's even more common in hierarchy
以至于谁都不愿意退让时，会发生什么呢？呃，你被击沉了。但是，那种困境本身就成了谈话的主题，那就是：我太沮丧、太心烦意乱或者别的什么了，以至于我无法真正参与到你的话题中。是的，我认为这在对话中经常发生。你在书中的一章中指出的一点让我觉得非常入迷，有时转换轨道是发生在一个人心里的，并没有真正大声说出来。你能谈谈这个吗？是的，我认为这在等级制度中更为常见，
when it's the person lower in the hierarchy, right? So your boss is chewing you out, and you're not saying anything out loud because you're You know actually smarter than that in that moment But what you're thinking of course is okay first of all this is not my fault And second of all you're even worse at this than I am and third of all I can't believe that you're doing this in front of everyone and you're this unprofessional
当处于等级较低的人身上时，对吧？所以你的老板正在训斥你，而你什么都没大声说出来，因为那一刻你其实比他更聪明。但你心里想的当然是：第一，这不是我的错；第二，你干这个甚至还不如我；第三，我简直不敢相信你竟然当着所有人的面这么做，你太不专业了。
You know and everybody by the way hates you right? So you are switching to about four other topics of your feedback for him or her But it's a silent switch track. So your boss isn't necessarily aware that you're not paying any attention at all Hang on I'm all I'm asking for here is a tiny bit of gratitude. I said thank you. No, you didn't. I was standing in the flowers. I said thank you the first time you gave me red roses. Remember, it was my birthday. I said thank you.
你知道的，而且顺便说一句，大家都讨厌你，对吧？所以你实际上是在对他（她）的反馈进行了大约另外四个话题的切换。但这是一种无声的轨道转换。所以你的老板不一定能察觉到你根本没有在听。“等一下，我在这里要求的只是一点点的感激之情。”“我说谢谢了。”“不，你没有。我就站在花旁边。”“你第一次送我红玫瑰的时候我说谢谢了。记得吗？那是我的生日。我说谢谢了。
And then I said very politely that I would prefer it in the future if you never again gave me red roses. So either you didn't listen or you don't care. Which isn't. LAUGHTER When you think about it, hearing feedback like this from a loved one or a close colleague can be really difficult. I ask Sheila why it seems easier to receive feedback
然后我很礼貌地表示，希望以后你再也别送我红玫瑰了。所以要么你没听，要么你根本不在乎。不是吗？”（笑声）仔细想想，从爱人或亲密同事那里听到这样的反馈真的很难。我问希拉，为什么从陌生人那里接收反馈，似乎比从与我们亲近的人那里接收要容易得多？
from strangers than from the people who are close to us. I think it's because it removes the tension of that, wanting to be accepted and respected and loved. I've had my husband come home and say, gosh, this new colleague has such an insightful comment. I think it's really gonna change the way I teach. And he tells me what it is and I think, uh-huh. And he says what?
我想这是因为这消除了那种渴望被接受、被尊重和被爱的紧张感。我曾听我丈夫回家后说：“天哪，这位新同事的评论太有见地了。我觉得这真的会改变我的教学方式。”然后他把内容告诉我，我想：“呃-哈。”他说：“怎么了？”
I say, nothing. He says what? I'm like nothing. He says, what? I'm like, okay, I've only been telling you that for 10 years. You know, now you know this guy for 10 minutes and he's like the voice of God about what's true about you. And I think that the fact that it's coming from someone who is a stranger or an acquaintance makes it less threatening in a way that enables us to hear it sometimes. There's a sadness to that, isn't there, Sheila,
我说：“没什么。”他说：“怎么了？”我说：“没什么。”他说：“怎么了？”我说：“好吧，我这话已经对你说了十年了。你知道的，现在你认识这家伙才十分钟，他就成了关于你自身真相的‘上帝之音’。”我认为，由于它是来自一个陌生人或熟人，这种方式在某种程度上减少了威胁感，从而使我们有时能够听进去。这里面有一种悲哀，对吧，希拉？
which is that we actually don't listen to the people who know us the best when in fact they are the people who could help us the most. Yeah, you know, they're the people who know us the best and love us the most, but they're also the people who want us to change the most. When I tell you things and you don't listen,
那就是我们实际上并不听那些最了解我们的人的话，而事实上他们才是最能帮助我们的人。是的，你知道的，他们是最了解我们、最爱我们的人，但他们也是最希望我们改变的人。当我跟你说事情而你却不听时，
it's a huge insult to me. It makes me feel like I don't matter. Believe me, I totally get this. You want me to listen to you, and then later remember the things that you say. Well, this has been wonderful. Sheila Hien, thank you for joining me today on The Hidden Brain. It was such a pleasure.
这对我是个巨大的侮辱。这让我觉得自己无足轻重。相信我，我完全理解这一点。你想让我听你说话，然后记住你以后说的话。好吧，这太棒了。希拉·海因，谢谢你今天来到“隐藏的大脑”。非常荣幸。
Sheila Hien and Douglas Stone teach negotiation at the Harvard Law School. They're also the authors of the best-selling book, Thanks for the Feedback. Sheila, that was awesome. I have to say that if you write a book about how you should be better at receiving feedback, there is a real peril here, which is that people are going to start giving you feedback and expect that you're going to be good at receiving it. Has that happened to you? Oh my goodness. If you want an extra help of criticism in your life, write a book on receiving feedback.
希拉·海因和道格拉斯·斯通在哈佛法学院教授谈判课程。他们也是畅销书《感谢反馈》的作者。希拉，那太棒了。我不得不说，如果你写了一本关于如何更好地接受反馈的书，这里面其实有一个真正的危险，那就是人们会开始给你反馈，并期望你擅长接受反馈。这发生在你身上过吗？天哪。如果你想在生活中获得额外剂量的批评，那就写一本关于接受反馈的书吧。
Holy cow. Okay, Adam Cole has been furiously taking notes so he can come up with a song about all the ideas in this podcast episode. Of course, being a typical artist, Adam neglected to bring in paper, so he can come up with a song about all the ideas in this podcast episode. Of course, being a typical artist, Adam neglected to bring in paper so he's writing on his own hands. You getting some ideas, Adam? I think I'm about to run out of handspace, gotta roll up my sleeves, use my arms. Alright, I'm afraid you're gonna have to take off your shirt and start writing on your
我的天啊。好的，亚当·科尔一直在狂热地做笔记，以便能写一首歌来概括这期播客节目中的所有想法。当然，作为一个典型的艺术家，亚当忘了带纸，所以他写歌来概括这期播客节目中的所有想法。当然，作为一个典型的艺术家，亚当忘了带纸，于是他在自己的手上写字。你有什么灵感了吗，亚当？我觉得我的手部空间快用完了，得把袖子卷起来，用胳膊写了。好吧，我恐怕你得脱掉衬衫开始在你的
biceps soon. Anyway, we'll be back in a moment for the next segment. We're gonna play a game called Stopwatch Science, Rapid Fire Ideas About Human Behavior with my friend, Daniel Pink. Back now for a new segment we'd like to introduce to you, we're calling it Stopwatch Science. I'm joined by Daniel Pink, whom we have anointed our senior StopWatScience correspondent.
二头肌上写字了。不管怎样，我们稍事休息后就会回来继续下一个环节。我们将和我的朋友丹尼尔·平克（Daniel Pink）一起玩一个名为“秒表科学”（Stopwatch Science）、关于人类行为的快问快答游戏。欢迎回到我们想向大家介绍的新环节，我们称之为“秒表科学”。和我一起的是丹尼尔·平克，我们已经封他为我们的高级“秒表科学”记者。
Hello, Dan. Hey, Shankar, great to be here. Dan is going to be a regular on the Hidden Brain podcast. He's the author of Drive to Sell is Human and Other Books, and like me, he has a passion for social science research. Totally. Let's explain to the listeners how this is going to work. Dan and I are going to share some interesting ideas
你好，丹。嘿，香卡，很高兴来到这里。丹将成为“隐藏的大脑”播客的常驻嘉宾。他是《驱动力》（Drive）、《全新思维》（A Whole New Mind）以及其他书籍的作者，和我一样，他对社会科学研究充满热情。确实如此。让我们向听众解释一下这个游戏怎么玩。我和丹将分享一些来自社会科学研究的有趣观点，
from social science research, but we each get only 60 seconds to do it. Can it be done? We found a way to keep each other honest. Dad's going to give me a warning, if I bump up against my time, and I'm going to play this sound if he hits one minute. OK, as we've heard, giving and receiving feedback can be difficult.
但我们每人只有60秒的时间。这能做到吗？我们找到了互相监督的方法。如果我超时了，丹会给我警告；如果他到了一分钟，我会播放这个声音。好的，正如我们所听到的，给予和接收反馈可能会很困难。
Dad and I are going to tell you four ways you can become a better listener and a better giver of advice. Dan, your 60 seconds starts now. Well, Shankar, as you said, we're always trying to get people to pay attention at school in the office, at home. But there's some research showing that we have a powerful weapon at our disposal. One of, in my view, the greatest inventions in American technological history, and that is,
丹和我将告诉你成为更好的倾听者和更好的建议提供者的四种方法。丹，你的60秒现在开始。嗯，香卡，正如你所说，我们总是试图让人们在学校、办公室、家里集中注意力。但有些研究表明，我们手里有一个强大的武器。在我看来，这是美国技术史上最伟大的发明之一，那就是——
the Post-It Note. The what? The Post-It Note, the sticky note. Randy Garner at Sam Houston State University did this amazing experiment a few years ago, and here's what he did. He was dealing with a really recounseltrant group of people, faculty members, and he wanted them
便签贴。什么？便签贴，就是那个粘性便签。萨姆休斯顿州立大学（Sam Houston State University）的兰迪·加纳（Randy Garner）几年前做了一个惊人的实验，他是这样做的。他当时面对的是一组非常顽固的人——教职员工，他想让他们
to fill out a survey, and he did a study where he gave some people just the survey. He gave some people with the surveys and a cover letter saying, please fill out the survey. And he gave others the survey with a little post-it note handwritten saying, would you please fill out the survey? Well, in the first two groups, fewer than a half of the faculty members returned the survey, completed the survey. But when he put the post-it note on there, the personalized post-it note, nearly 70% of people completed the survey completed the survey, but when he put the post it note on there the personalized post it note
填一份调查问卷。他做了一项研究，给一些人只发了调查问卷；给一些人发了调查问卷和一封附信，上面写着“请填写这份调查问卷”；还给另一些人发了调查问卷，上面附带一张手写的便签贴，写着“请问你能填一下这份调查问卷吗？”结果，在前两组中，只有不到一半的教职员工交回并完成了调查问卷；但当他在上面贴了便签贴、那张个性化的便签贴时，
nearly 70% of people Completed the survey. Wow, and I think the reason is simple It's personal and it's a little bit reciprocal So if you want someone to do something put a post it note I really like that Dan So the next time I know when you bump up against your 60 seconds instead of playing an ineffectual buzzer I'm just gonna hold up a post it now That's actually probably pretty good idea you bump up against your 60 seconds instead of playing an ineffectual buzzer, I'm just going to hold up a post it now.
近70%的人完成了调查问卷。哇，我想原因很简单：它很个性化，而且带有一点互惠性。所以如果你想让别人做某事，贴个便签贴吧。我真的很喜欢那个，丹。所以下次我知道了，当你超时的时候，我不再播放无效的蜂鸣器，而是举起一张便签贴。这其实是个挺不错的主意。当你超时的时候，我不再播放无效的蜂鸣器，而是举起一张便签贴。
That's actually probably a pretty good idea. So I don't have a post it note right now, but I do have a timer, and Shankar, your one minute starts right now. All right, when someone gives you feedback, there's two ways to think about it, Dan. You can say, okay, I'll take this advice, or you can say, why is this person telling me this? You can question the motives of the advisor. A few years ago, Max Gunter, at Vanderbilt University and his colleagues, the analyzed the brains of the advisor. A few years ago, Max Gunther, at Van Dybelth University and his colleagues,
这其实是个挺不错的主意。所以现在我没有便签贴，但我有一个计时器，香卡，你的一分钟现在开始。好的，当别人给你反馈时，有两种思考方式，丹。你可以说：“好吧，我接受这个建议”；或者你可以说：“这个人为什么要告诉我这个？”你可以质疑建议者的动机。几年前，范德堡大学（Vanderbilt University）的马克斯·冈瑟（Max Gunther）和他的同事们分析了建议者的脑部。几年前，范德堡大学的马克斯·冈瑟和他的同事们
they analyzed the brains of men, they stuck them in a brain scanner, and piped in the voices of their wives, giving them advice about some issue. And he found that when the advice was in a subject where the man thought of himself as being an expert, Advice from the wives activated a part of the brain that is observed when we try to guess what's happening in another person's mind. So Gunther and his colleagues are speculating that when these men received advice on a subject that was close to home, their reaction, their first reaction, was to question the motives of their wives. So, instead of evaluating the advice on its own terms, these men are asking, why is my wife giving me that kind of advice?
分析了男性的脑部，他们把这些男主角塞进脑部扫描仪里，并播放他们妻子就某些问题给出建议的声音。他发现，当建议涉及男性自认为专家的领域时，来自妻子的建议会激活大脑中一个在我们试图猜测别人脑子里在想什么时被观察到的区域。所以冈瑟和他的同事推测，当这些男性收到关于他们熟知领域的建议时，他们的反应——他们的第一反应——是质疑妻子的动机。所以，这些男性没有根据建议本身的价值去评估它，而是质问：“我妻子为什么要给我这种建议？”
So, here's the take-home message. Be really careful about offering advice. If you're given advice, listen to the advice instead of questioning the motives of the person who's giving it to you. That is actually great advice, truly, truly. And because again, when I hear something that I disagree with, I basically want to question the motives of the person
所以，带回家去的核心信息是：在提供建议时要非常小心。如果你得到了建议，请认真听取建议，而不是去质疑那个给你建议的人的动机。这真的是个极好的建议，千真万确。因为同样地，当我听到不同意的观点时，我基本上就想去质疑那个
who's giving me the advice or telling me what I want to think. I do it all the time. Very, very good. I do it all the time. I think it's a great guidance out there simply to navigate life, to assume positive intent and let time to do that. Very, very good. I do it all the time. I think there's a great guidance out there simply to navigate life to assume positive intent and let people disprove that. Rather than do what I do, we'll just assume negative, insidious intent and wait for people
给我建议或告诉我该怎么想的人的动机。我总是这样。非常非常棒。我总是这样。我认为这是一个很好的指导原则，只需以此来指望生活：假定别人怀有善意，并让时间来证明。非常非常棒。我总是这样。我认为这是一个很好的指导原则，只需以此来指望生活，假定别人怀有善意，并让人们去打破这种印象。而不是像我那样，只去假定别人怀有阴险的恶意，然后等着看他们是否能
to be shown to be good people. Great advice. Well, completely agree with you Dan, but there doesn't relieve you of the opportunity to actually deliver your next business. Social Science Research in under 60 seconds. If you're ready, your time starts now. now so many decades ago there was a famous commercial that said if you want to get someone's attention whisper now that might be true but here's the other question if you're gonna whisper into which ear should you
被证明是好人。绝佳的建议。好吧，完全同意你的观点，丹，但这并不能免除你发表下一个商业见解的机会。在60秒内完成社会科学研究。如果你准备好了，你的计时现在开始。几十年前，有一个著名的广告说：“如果你想引起某人的注意，就去耳语。”这也许是对的，但这里还有另一个问题：如果你要耳语，应该对着哪只耳朵
whisper well it turns out the two Italian cognitive scientists look at oh boy look at Tomassi and and Daniellei Marzoli have analyzed this question. They went to a nightclub, and they wanted to see in this crowded noisy nightclub, are people talking to each other, into their right ear, into their left ear. And in an overwhelming number, 72%,
耳语呢？事实是，两位意大利认知科学家——哦，天哪，看这名字——托马西（Tommasi）和达尼埃莱·马尔佐利（Daniele Marzoli）分析了这个问题。他们去了一家夜店，想看看在这个拥挤嘈杂的夜店里，人们在互相交谈时，是对着右耳还是左耳说话。绝大多数，即72%，
they were favoring the right ear. Then it gets even more interesting. They conduct an experiment in that nightclub, asking people for cigarettes where people more likely to give a cigarette if you ask them in the right ear or if you ask them in the left ear and low and behold big numbers, you got to cigarette if you ask people in their right ear. Now there's a brain reason for that. Our brains are contralateral, left hemisphere controls are rights out of the body, left hemisphere controls verbal communication.
他们倾向于右耳。接下来更有趣的是。他们在那个夜店做了一个实验，向人们要香烟，看看当你在右耳还是左耳向他们要烟时，人们是否更有可能给你烟。不出所料，数字很惊人，如果你对着人们的右耳要烟，你就能要到烟。这背后是有大脑科学原因的。我们的大脑是对侧支配的，左半球控制身体右侧，左半球控制语言沟通。
So if you want to get someone's attention whisper Into their right ear. I got to remember this. I don't know what my editor is going to think when I sidel up next to her and whisper in her ear I suspect HR might get called in at some point. Yeah, I don't I want you to avoid I want you to avoid that just you know Buy us yourself toward the right but more important buy us yourself toward doing your assignment here, Sean car Buy us yourself toward the right, but more important, buy us yourself toward doing your assignment here, Shankar. Your next one minute starts right now. All right, as we know, it's hard to get people to listen to the things you have to say,
所以如果你想引起某人的注意，就对着他（她）的右耳耳语。我得记住这个。我不知道当我悄悄走到编辑身边并在她耳边耳语时，她会怎么想。我猜人力资源部可能随时会介入。是的，我不想——我希望你避免那样做，只需（笑声）把你的偏好倾向于右侧，但更重要的是，香卡，把你的偏好倾向于完成你这里的任务。把你的偏好倾向于右侧，但更重要的是，香卡，把你的偏好倾向于完成你这里的任务。你的下一个一分钟现在开始。好的，正如我们所知，很难让别人听你说话，
but besides whispering in their right ear, research has also found another technique that shows some promise. Basically, it's self-flattery. Self-flattery. Here's what I mean. The reason people resist threatening information is that it's painful. If you can boost the person's self-esteem before he or she is given threatening information, that might make them more receptive for this kind of information.
但除了对着他们的右耳耳语之外，研究还发现另一种很有前景的技术。基本上，这就是自我吹捧。自我吹捧。我是这个意思。人们排斥具有威胁性的信息，是因为它很痛苦。如果你能在向某人提供具有威胁性的信息之前提升其自尊，这可能会使他们对这类信息的接受度更高。
Tracy Epton at the University of Manchester and her colleagues recently analyzed 144 experiments into the effects of self-affirmation. They find a pattern. When you ask people to reflect on some value they hold dear, when you ask them to write a short essay about their personal, positive qualities, they are more likely to accept information that is threatening or unpleasant. So in other words, the next time before you tell me what I'm doing wrong then, please make sure you compliment me on my courage in the face of adversity and the kindness that
曼彻斯特大学（University of Manchester）的特蕾西·埃普顿（Tracy Epton）和她的同事最近分析了144个关于自我肯定效果的实验。他们发现了一种模式。当你让人们反思他们珍视的某种价值观，当你让他们写一篇关于他们个人积极品质的短文时，他们更有可能接受那些具有威胁性或令人不快的信息。换句话说，下次在你指出我哪里做得不对之前，丹，请确保先称赞我面对逆境时的勇气，以及我对
I display towards soft, fiery animals. Well, that's great. You are a wonderful human being, a great father, a wonderful husband, a brilliant journalist, but you blew your time by ten seconds. I'm gonna take that to heart. I was stop what science. I'm Shankar Vitaanthum. And I'm Daniel Pink. Adam, can you hear me? Well, you have my attention, but unfortunately I'm wearing stereo headphones, so... Oh, the right ear. But I will say that is probably the most Italian study I've ever heard of the, you know,
柔软、毛茸茸的小动物所表现出的仁慈。好吧，这太棒了。你是一个了不起的人、一个好父亲、一个好丈夫、一个出色的记者，但你超出了十秒钟的时间。我会把这记在心里。这就是“秒表科学”。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。我是丹尼尔·平克。亚当，你能听到我说话吗？嗯，你吸引了我的注意力，但不幸的是我戴着立体声耳机，所以……
cigarettes and nightclub study. Yeah, I suspect that if we pulled people in Italy about it, they would say those are tax dollars' wealth spend. Very much so, yeah. Alright, when we come back, I'm going to play Adam one final segment. I decided to sit down with a friend at a nice tea shop and talk about the importance of quiet rituals in our lives. But that conversation got switched track by an unexpected visitor.
哦，右耳。但我必须说，这大概是我听过的最具有意大利风格的研究了，你知道的，香烟和夜店的研究。是的，我猜如果我们去意大利就此民调，他们会说那是纳税人的钱花得其值得。确实如此，是的。好的，当我们回来时，我要给亚当播放最后一个环节。我决定和一个朋友坐在一家漂亮的茶馆里，聊聊生活中安静的仪式感的重要性。但那场谈话却被一个不速之客给“转换轨道”了。
Is that a wreck? Stick around. Welcome back to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vidant. I want to introduce you to a friend of mine, Misha, the Indie mom of comedy. What's an Indie mom? I let Misha explain. An Indie mom is a woman who believes that it's okay and great to be a mom and it's awesome to be a wife, but you've got to hold on to yourself as well. You've got to have some balancing your life. And my mantra is in order to be a good indie mom, you still have to be innovative and independent in a lot of ways. And what has helped me stay innovative is leaving a PhD program and becoming a stand-up
那是一只老鼠吗？别走开。欢迎回到“隐藏的大脑”。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。我想向大家介绍我的一个朋友米莎（Misha），喜剧界的独立妈妈。什么是独立妈妈？我让米莎来解释一下。独立妈妈是指这样一位女性：她认为做母亲是可以的、也是伟大的，做妻子也很棒，但你必须同时坚守自我。你的生活中必须有某种平衡。我的座右铭是，为了成为一个好的独立妈妈，你在很多方面仍然必须具有创新性和独立性。而帮助我保持创新的正是离开博士项目并成为一名单口喜剧演员。
comic. That was a very innovative idea. If anyone knows how to slow things down a little bit and to manage a very busy lifestyle, that would be Misha. Now, in addition to being the mother of three, she's also a comic, an actress, a public speaker, and despite leaving that PhD program, Misha is still very much interested in psychology, which is why I thought she would be the perfect friend to talk about the importance of ritual in our daily lives. I caught up with her at a delightful tea shop in Washington, DC,
那真是一个极具创新的想法。如果有人知道如何让生活慢下来一点并管理极其忙碌的生活方式，那一定就是米莎。除了是三个孩子的母亲之外，她还是一名喜剧演员、演员、公众演讲者，尽管离开了那个博士项目，米莎对心理学仍然非常感兴趣，这就是为什么我认为她是谈论仪式在我们日常生活中重要性的绝佳朋友。我在华盛顿特区一家名为Capital Teas的 delightful 茶馆里见到了她，
called Capital Teas. Let's go get tea. Oh my god, look at these choices. You see all the choices? There's like, how many teas are here? It's like, so the trick is to open the jars and smell the teas. May I smell that? It's roasted almond.
让我们去喝茶吧。哦，天哪，看看这些选择。你看到所有的选择了吗？这里大概有，这里有多少种茶？所以秘诀就是打开罐子闻闻茶香。我可以闻一下这个吗？这是烤杏仁。
Oh, it's so good. Like it's the bucket of awesome. Our host Nata began to make our tea first scooping out delicate mounds of tea into glass pots and drowning the leaves in steaming hot water. See all these little nuances that we learned from being in an authentic tea house? I would just pay to watch this, let alone drink this, I would just pay to watch. This is a culture. You know, there's a researcher at the Harvard Business School called Francesca Gino, and she's done a lot of work looking at the effects that rituals have on our enjoyment of
哦，太棒了。就像是个“超级大杂烩”。我们的店主娜塔（Nata）开始为我们泡茶，先用小勺将精致的茶叶舀进玻璃壶中，然后用滚烫的热水浸泡茶叶。看到所有这些我们从真正的茶馆里学到的细微差别了吗？我光是付钱看这个都愿意，更不用说喝了，我光是付钱看就愿意。这是一种文化。你知道的，哈佛商学院有一位研究员叫弗兰西斯卡·吉诺（Francesca Gino），她做了很多研究，探讨仪式对我们享受事物乐趣的影响。
things. That if you actually build ritual into the process of enjoying something, which is exactly what we're doing here, I suspect it's going to greatly increase our satisfaction with this cup of tea. I concur, and I'm not a scientist. What I do know for sure is that I'm very excited in this very moment. And I think the ritual has really added to the excitement. Because typically, when you think tea, you think hot water and a tea bag typically, isn't that what you think?
如果你在享受事物的过程中真正建立起仪式感，而这正是我们在这里所做的，我猜这会大大增加我们对这杯茶的满意度。我完全同意，虽然我不是科学家。我确切知道的是，此时此刻我非常兴奋。而且我认为仪式感确实增添了兴奋感。因为通常情况下，当你想到茶时，你想到的是热水和一个茶包，通常是这样，难道不是吗？
That's what I do in a micro. Like the cushy chair. Would you like the cushy chair? But you know, here's a cultural thing for me though. I've been raised to never allow the man to sit with his back to the door. Really? Yes, because I was taught that if anything
我通常在微波炉里那样做。比如那个舒适的椅子。你想要那把舒适的椅子吗？但你知道，对我来说这是一种文化习惯。我从小受到的教育是，绝对不要让男人背对门坐着。真的吗？是的，因为我被教导说，如果发生任何
I'm for seeing where to happen, the man should be ready to protect you. Yeah. So if I sit in that chair, I'm breaking culture. So there's two problems with that theory. Okay, what's the theory? The first thing is that we're sitting in this very peaceful t-shop, where it's very unlikely anything would happen. But the second problem and
不测的话，男人应该随时准备保护你。所以如果我坐那把椅子，我就违背了文化。那这个理论有两个问题。好的，是什么理论？第一件事是，我们正坐在一个非常宁静的茶馆里，发生任何事情的可能性都微乎其微。但第二个问题
the bigger problem is if something were to happen, I am not the kind of guy who would actually be able to save you, Michelle. That is very, very unlikely. Now, explain to me, are you allowed to clink monks before before you drink tea? I think we can. Alright. Sublime. Sublime. Sublime is a great word.
也是更大的问题是：如果真的发生了什么，我可不是那种实际上能够救你的人，米莎。那是非常非常不可能的。现在，向我解释一下，你在喝茶之前可以碰杯吗？我想我们可以。好的。绝妙。绝妙是个好词。
Absolutely wonderful. Thank you so much. That's a great cup of tea. Oh, mine turned out great. But I have to say, it's the whole ritual of it that really I think is doing it for me, because it's made me slow down, it made me watch, it made me observe as the tea was being made. I never do those things, I never slow down, I'm always, I pop the tea to the microwave and then I-
绝对太棒了。非常感谢。这杯茶真好喝。哦，我的泡得好极了。但我必须说，整个仪式感才是真正对起作用的地方，因为它让我慢下来，让我观看，让我在泡茶的过程中进行观察。我从不做这些事，我从不慢下来，我总是——我把茶塞进微波炉然后我——
You don't even boil the water in your- Are you kidding me? Are you kidding me? Are you kidding me? I need the water. For me, it's what you said earlier about the research, about ritual, because as a stand-up, you have to be very quick, you have to be on your feet, you have to be very improvisational, if you're going to have any level of success. And yet, I believe the reason why I have any level of success as a stand-up is because I have employed so many rituals into my daily life.
你甚至不在你的——里烧水？你在开玩笑吗？你在开玩笑吗？你在开玩笑吗？我需要水。对我来说，就是你刚才说的关于研究、关于仪式的内容，因为作为一名单口喜剧演员，你必须反应非常快，你必须当机立断，如果你想取得任何程度的成功，你必须极具即兴表演能力。然而，我相信我作为单口喜剧演员之所以能取得任何程度的成功，是因为我在日常生活中融入了如此多的仪式。
So let me ask you a question. When I leap out of bed in the morning, every morning, saying, oh my God, I'm late. Oh my God, there's six things that I have to do and I have time for only three. But if I do this every single morning, does that count as a ritual? No, that's pandemonium. I don't know what the ham sandwich that is. That sounds a bit like... Michelle tried to convince me of the benefits of slowing down.
所以让我问你一个问题。当我每天早晨从床上跳起来，每天早晨都说：“哦天哪，我迟到了。哦天哪，有六件事我必须要做，而我只有做三件事的时间。”但如果我每天早晨都这样做，这算是一个仪式吗？不，那是大混乱。我不知道那是哪门子的火腿三明治。听起来有点像……米莎试图说服我放慢脚步的好处。
This right here... Yes. ...gives me an immense amount of pleasure. This, this right here, listen. I can see that and I'm so happy for you. Like, I'm very happy in this very moment. I just don't end and I have it. Is that, what is that?
这块……是的……给我带来了巨大的快乐。这块，这块，听着。我能看出这一点，我为你感到高兴。比如，此时此刻我非常高兴。我只是没有停下来拥有它。那是，那是什么？
Walking in there, what was that? Much to our surprise, a rat from the patio outside decided to join us. It stood up on its hind legs and poked its head through the doorway. OMG, Shanker, he's out there, close the door. Do you see him?
走进来的那个，那是什么？令我们惊讶的是，外面露台上一只老鼠决定加入我们。它用后腿站立，把头探进了门口。天哪，香卡，它在外面，关门！你看到它了吗？
I will not, that in this instance, even though I said I would be unable to turn the door into a new place. Michelle did not leap up to close the door. Michelle, who turned her face to the wall and said, oh, and g, that was her response to the coming catastrophe. And she turned to me, the person who is not widely advertised as being the leading man.
我不会的，在这种情况下，尽管我说过我无法把门变成一个新地方。米莎并没有跳起来去关门。米莎把脸转向墙说：“哦，天哪”，那是她对即将到来的灾难的反应。然后她转向我——那个并没有被广泛宣传为男主角的人，
And you have to, to me, to close the door. What you did, you rose to the occasion. I love to meet the close the door. I didn't. So maybe there's something to these traditions and rituals after all. From now on I am going to make sure I sit facing the door so I can always deal with incoming rodents. After my heroic gesture we finished our tea almost 90 minutes after entering the tea house. It was a rare pleasure to slow down, to discover the ritual of tea making, and to see how much it enhanced our experience. She has to make the tea that way in order for it to turn out this way.
而你得去把门关上。你做到了，你从容应对了。我喜欢去关门。我没有。所以也许这些传统和仪式还是有道理的。从现在开始，我要确保我面对着门坐，这样我总能应付进来的啮齿动物。在我完成英雄般的举动后，我们在进入茶馆大约90分钟后喝完了茶。放慢脚步、探索泡茶的仪式感并看到它如何增强我们的体验，这是一种难得的快乐。她必须那样泡茶，才能泡出这种味道。
If not, if she breaks that ritual, it's a different taste. If she microwaves it and sticks it in. Yeah, like if she does the shanker method. The shanker method. Yes. And we won't have this experience. We wouldn't have this experience. We wouldn't, it would be much more efficient though I would add, but we wouldn't have the experience. Efficiency doesn't always equal happiness. So people have been telling me for many years. Michelle, I want to thank you for talking with me today. This has been a pleasure. It's been a pleasure too, Shankar. Thank you.
如果不这样，如果她打破了那个仪式，那就是另一种味道了。如果她用微波炉加热并塞进去的话。是的，就像她采用“香卡方法”一样。“香卡方法”。是的。我们就不会有这种体验了。我们就不会有这种体验了。我们不会有，尽管我得补充说，那样会高效得多，但我们就不会有这种体验了。高效并不总是等同于快乐。正如人们多年来一直对我说的那样。米莎，我想谢谢你今天和我交谈。这真是一种享受。这也是一种享受，香卡。谢谢你。
Okay Adam, I'm relaxed after that cup of tea, the ritual of the tea making, but what do you think? Do you have enough material to come up with an original song? Well, I'm not relaxed, because I'm gonna have to put this all together, but I'm gonna go back into the old skunk bear cave and see what I can come up with. All right, let's see what you do. See you in a bit.
好的，亚当，喝完那杯茶、体验了泡茶的仪式感后，我放松下来了，但你觉得呢？你有足够的素材来创作一首原创歌曲吗？嗯，我一点也不放松，因为我得把这一切拼凑起来，但我打算回到旧的“臭鼬熊”洞穴里去，看看我能想出什么来。好的，让我们看看你的表现。一会儿见。
Through the magic of audio, Adam has gone away for several days and now has re-emerged from his skunk bear cave. How did it go, Adam? Well, it went okay. I sort of was going off this sort of back and forth nature of this whole episode. So imagine a less talented Gershwin brother writing a musical, probably called something like all aboard with a train theme. Ginger Rogers, Fred Astaire, have a little back and forth here. And you did this all by yourself? Well, I got a friend, Amanda McQueen, to help me out.
通过音频的魔术，亚当离开了好几天，现在从他的“臭鼬熊”洞穴里重新出现了。进展得怎么样，亚当？嗯，还行。我有点顺着这整期节目中这种来来回回的特质来创作。所以想象一下，一个才华不如格什温（Gershwin）的兄弟在写一部音乐剧，可能取名为诸如带有火车主题的《全员上车》之类的。金格·罗杰斯（Ginger Rogers）、弗雷德·阿斯泰尔（Fred Astaire），在这里进行一点来来回回的互动。这些都是你一个人完成的吗？嗯，我找了个朋友阿曼达·麦昆（Amanda McQueen）来帮我。
So yeah, here we go. All right, let's hear what you came up with. I think you'll find I've got a one track mind with just one train of thought. It's you my love, I'm thinking of for you a gift I bought I'm just a romantic, I suppose So, without further ado, here's my present for you
所以，是的，我们开始吧。好的，让我们听听你想出了什么。你会发现我有单一的想法，只有一个思维轨迹。那是你，我爱的人，我为你买了一件礼物，我只是个浪漫主义者，我想。所以，废话不多说，这是我送你的礼物
One, rent, rose One Rind Rose You should know this, I don't like roses Especially when they're red Hey, show some restraint Save the complaint and maybe start with thanks instead You just don't listen I already said it But when a gift is given I mean, come on You just don't listen, I already said it
一朵红玫瑰，一朵红玫瑰。你应该知道这个，我不喜欢玫瑰，尤其是当它们是红色的。嘿，克制一点，省省抱怨，也许应该先说声谢谢。你根本不听，我已经说过了，但当别人送礼物时，拜托，得了吧。你根本不听，我已经说过了，
But when a gift is given, I mean, come on You just don't get it, now we're Swiss tracking I'm this close to sending you packing You don't exude much gratitude You're not hearing, you're just reacting But I love you When you love me So let's slow down and share a cup of tea Well, I won't fear the things I hear
但当别人送礼物时，拜托，得了吧。你根本不懂，现在我们在转换轨道了，我离把你打包送走只有一步之遥了。你没散发出多少感激之情，你没有在听，你只是在反应。但我爱你，当你爱我的时候，所以让我们慢下来，分享一杯茶吧。嗯，我不会害怕我听到的事情，
If you prime my mind with praise Whisper deer in my right ear And all except the whispered phrase And if something works you, just like that rose did This might work, you just put your problems on a post-it Now we're swish-jacking on this post The same, the new packing, you don't exude much gratitude You're not hearing, you're just reacting
如果你用赞美来启发我的思维，在我的右耳耳语，小鹿（Dear），除了那句耳语之外的其他一切。如果有什么方法对你有用，就像那朵玫瑰那样，这也许管用，你只要把你的问题写在便签贴上。现在我们在便签贴上转换轨道了，同样的，新的打包，你没散发出多少感激之情，你没有在听，你只是在反应。
But I love you and you love me So let's slow down and share a cup of I just cannot get enough of Let's slow down and share a cup of tea Adam, that was fantastic I'm gonna get a carrot cup of tea. Adam, that was fantastic! Oh, thank you so much. You don't exude much gratitude. I love that!
但我爱你，你也爱我，所以让我们慢下来，分享一杯——我简直无餍无足——让我们慢下来，分享一杯茶吧。亚当，那太棒了。我要去拿杯茶。亚当，那太棒了！哦，非常感谢。你没散发出多少感激之情。我太喜欢这个了！
Adam Cole, thank you so much for playing our game. Well, thanks so much for having me on. Will you be back again? I definitely will. Great. Well, let's give this game a name. Uh, here's what I'm thinking. How about Cole play? Well, let's give this game a name. Here's what I'm thinking. How about Coldplay? Well, let's keep thinking on it.
亚当·科尔，非常感谢你来玩我们的游戏。哦，非常感谢邀请我来。你还会再来吗？我一定会来的。太好了。好吧，我们给这个游戏起个名字吧。嗯，我是这么想的：要不叫“科尔玩”（Coleplay）？好吧，我们再想想看。
Since this is our very first episode, there are a lot of people we have to thank. The Embry Family Foundation, and specifically Lauren Embry and Diane Hosey, helped us get off the ground and so did Heather and Paul Hega, Paul and Marsha Ginsberg, Anne and John Herman, Antoine and Emily Van Achtmel. John R and Tonna B Farmer, the Mosaic Foundation of R&P Hayden, Howard and Barbara Woolner and Patricia Papper. We couldn't have gotten off the ground without you. Special thanks today to Adam Cole and Amanda McQueen. You can see more of Adam's work on Tumblr and YouTube at Sconk Bear. This episode of the Hidden Brain Podcast is produced by Cara McGurk Allison and Maggie Penman.
既然这是我们的第一期节目，我们要感谢很多人。埃姆里家族基金会（The Embry Family Foundation），特别是劳伦·埃姆里（Lauren Embry）和黛安·霍西（Diane Hosey），帮助我们起步，海瑟和保罗·赫加（Heather and Paul Hega）、保罗和玛莎·金斯伯格（Paul and Marsha Ginsberg）、安和约翰·赫尔曼（Anne and John Herman）、安托万和艾米丽·范·阿赫特梅尔（Antoine and Emily Van Achtmel）。约翰·R和托娜·B·法莫（John R and Tonna B Farmer）、R&P海登马赛克基金会（The Mosaic Foundation of R&P Hayden）、霍华德和芭芭拉·伍尔纳（Howard and Barbara Woolner）以及帕特里夏·帕珀（Patricia Papper）。没有你们，我们不可能顺利起步。今天特别感谢亚当·科尔和阿曼达·麦昆。你可以在Tumblr和YouTube上的“臭鼬熊”（Skunk Bear）频道看到更多亚当的作品。本期“隐藏的大脑”播客由卡拉·麦克古克·艾利森（Cara McGurk Allison）和玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）制作。
Join us next week when we talk about the consequences of near misses and the surprising way losses can motivate us. I'm Shankar Vidantum and this is NPR. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下周请继续收听，我们将探讨与擦肩而过相关的后果以及失利激励我们的惊人方式。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。